مع اخر التطورات الميدانيه في حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا حيث حذرت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه من خطر الاستهداف بصواريخ
باليستيه في مناطق دينيبرو بتروفيسك
في الاثناء افاد مراسل الجزيره بوقوع
سلسله انفجارات في مدينه
الشرقيه اوكرانيا ورصدت كاميرا الجزيره
تصاعد اعمده الدخان من احد الاحياء
بالتزامن مع سفارات الانذار بالمدينه
وقالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه انها صدت
هجوما صاروخيا استهدف العاصمه
في اضرار ماديه جنوبا اعلنت السلطات
الاوكرانيه في خرسون عن مقتل شخصين واصابه
25 اخرين في هجوم للقوات الروسيه استهدف
المدينه وقال المتحدث باسم قوات الجنوب في
الجيش الروسي ان القوات الروسيه تصدت
هجمات اوكرانيه في خمس مناطق قرب ضخمه
واضاف المتحدث ان قوات الجنوب استهدفت
معاقل القوات الاوكرانيه حيث شنت الطيران
ضربات صاروخيه والقى قنابل على معاقل
ومخازن الاسلحه والمعدات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه في اتجاهات سوليدار بخموت
واليكساندرو كالينوسكي
وقالت وزاره دفاع روسيه انها ارسلت اكثر
من 4000 مدفعيه الى منطقه العمليه الخاصه
و700 اخرى ستصل قريبا واضافه وزير الدفاع
تفقد مؤسسه الصناعي العسكري في منطقه
اومسكا وامر بتوسيع القدرات الانتاجيه
للدبابات وانظمه اللهب الثقيله لتلبيه
احتياجات القوات الروسيه التي تؤدي مهام
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
الى مراسلنا ينضم الينا من ذا فالوجيا
مراسل جزيره حسان مسعود
ورانيا دريدي تنضم الينا من على ما يبدو
طيب حسان ابدا معك اطلعنا على الانفجارات
التي حدثت فيزا بيولوجيا وعن التحذير
الاوكراني من صواريخ روسيه بالستيه متوقعه
على مناطق في اوكرانيا
نعم جلال بينما نتحدث الان ما زال الخطر
الجوي قائم هنا في المنطقه الجنوبيه
والجنوبيه الشرقيه لاوكرانيا
بصواريخ مرتقبه يمكن ان تصل في اي لحظه
الى هذه المناطق من الطراز البالستي هذه
الصواريخ التي تنطلق بسرعه كبيره تعبر
الغلاف الجوي ثم تنطلق باتجاه اهدافها هذا
الامر على ما يبدو انه حدث فجر هذا اليوم
عند تمام الساعه الرابعه فجرا دوت
انفجارات في منطقه قريبه من وسط المدينه
من حيث وجد الان
وبعد دويه الانفجارات
بثوان دوت صفارات الانذار هذا يعني ان
الصواريخ التي اطلقت نحو مدينه صباح هذا
اليوم كانت سريعه للغايه لدرجه ان صفارات
الانذار اجهزه الانذار لم تستطع ان
تلتقطها قبل ان تصل الى اهدافها بعد ذلك
ايضا دوت انفجارات اخرى في سلسله من
الانفجارات
هنا لم تعلق حتى هذه اللحظه عن الموقع
الذي تم استهدافه ولكن ما يجري في هذه
المنطقه منطقه زبولوجيا والمناطق المحيطه
بالجبهات هو تكثيف للضربات الصاروخيه
موسعه على عدد من المناطق على طول الجبهات
التي ايضا هي جبهات مختلفه
وممتده على طول
المساحه الواصله من المنطقه الشرقيه من
دنياتك تحديدا من محيط منطقه بخموت حيث
تشتعل الاشتباكات هناك وتحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه على لساني قاده القوات
الاوكرانيه والمتحدثين العسكريين الرسميين
التقدم باتجاه منطقه شمال وجنوب باخمت
وكذلك على عدد من المحاور جنوب مقاطعه
وكذلك باتجاه المنطقه الواصله بين مقاطعتي
زابولوجيا
وحتى وصولا الى غرب مقاطعه زابولوجيا حيث
انا القوات الاوكرانيه تنفيذ عدد من
الهجمات اخر المعلومات حول التطورات على
الجبهات جاءت على لسان نائبه وزير الدفاع
التي قالت ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول
التقدم عند كل هذه الجبهات التي اشرنا
اليها في باخم تقول ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تقوم بشن هجمات لكن القوات الروسيه تقوم
بتعزيز قواتها باتجاه باخموت واستخدام
المزيد من القوات في تلك المنطقه اما في
المنطقه الواقعه والتي تسمى منطقه تافريا
وتشمل جنوب مقاطعه سافروجي وجنوب مقاطعه
هذه المنطقه تقول نائبه وزير الدفاع ان
مليار ان القوات الاوكرانيه تمكنت من
التقدم بحدود كيلومترين على طول هذه
الجبهه وهي تحقق تقدما تكتيكيا وفق قولها
ولكن في ذات الوقت هي تشير بشكل واضح الى
صعوبه المعارك في هذه الجبهات والى وجود
حقول الغام تواجه القوات الاوكرانيه من
خلال محاولتها التقدم عند هذه المحاور هذه
ايضا الاشارات هي اتت على لسان عدد من
المسؤولين الذين يقولون ان المواجهات خلال
تنفيذ هذه الهجمات المضاده كما تسميها
اوكرانيا هي قويه وقويه للغايه بشكل مختلف
عن الهجمات المضاده التي نفذتها بشكل سابق
في خارقسون وكيف وغيرها من المناطق
الاوكرانيه